what happened you've lost five million
dollars back another episode of the
greatest podcast ever created my first
million oh what's going on how are you
I'm thriving I'm actually really hot in
this room but I'm thriving you want to
talk about Andrew will consider I've
been thinking about him a lot he's on
your mind got a crush let's see on your
mind yeah I mean we did an episode with
him I thought was great I think he's
great
and the reaction was great so that's
triple great for Maya and what's on your
mind I just think he's great in say
think it's you I just think that he was
smart good attitude I think that the
reason I like talking to him is because
as I'm in San Francisco there's this
constant mindset that I'm so thankful
that I've surrounded myself with which
is all these people who like have these
ideas and someone were really dumb ideas
and they raise a lot of money for them
and they become huge and some of the
dumb ideas become awesome and that's
fantastic and a lot of the dumb ideas
remain dumb and just a lot of money was
wasted and there's just a lot of
mentality things that are in San
Francisco that I love but a lot of it
has downsides it's nice to hear
something from Andrew who just totally
does not do anything that I'm used to
and I love it yeah I also like how he's
kind of a one-man crew like I know he
obviously has CEOs for companies and it
sounds like he has a partner but like I
read his blog that Tim writing when we
were you know when we're talking on the
phone the strategy is like he thought it
was he's an original thinker so he
basically decided how he wanted to live
his life and then lived his life that
way and his decision was his it was not
like oh I just chose of these five
popular paths
I picked path for it's like now he
picked path 7 which was just a path they
you know him and few other people have
made for themselves yeah I just always
think it's great to hear from people who
do things totally different than what
you think you should be doing and it's
just nice to hear there's a fresh
perspective and
for those who don't know didn't listen
didn't care the things in my opinion
that he did differently sort of like
okay where did he say who andrew is oh
yeah so Andrew he owns his company
called tiny if you go to tiny capital
calm you could see it and he's trying to
do this sort of Warren Buffett model
where he buys what he thinks are
wonderful businesses he plans to hold
them for a long time he has operators
who run them and he has a holding
company that owns all of them and sort
of the net value is you know over a
hundred million dollars for these
companies down he's he basically had
nobody in the way that he financed it
was he started an agency when he was
nineteen he's probably thirty-three
thirty-four now right and so that like a
little cash cow
exactly so started that agency kind of
in his parents basement type of thing
did that for many years like I don't
know a decade or so and then got it to
the point where he had a bunch of free
cash flows like okay what do I do with
this money and decided to invest it
buying business so well the way I think
he zigged what everyone else sagged was
the Canada decision so contrary you know
so what conventional wisdom is you gotta
be in Silicon Valley you got to be New
York LA wherever wherever the hubs are
and he was like no I'm gonna live where
I want to live and I'm gonna take
advantage of some of the arbitrage
opportunities of you know he charged San
Francisco rates to his companies he was
doing designs for but he paid his people
you know local rates for doing the work
that they were doing and so his agency
was wildly profitable and that
compounded over like a decade which is
great so Canada was one contrary
decision the other one was buying
businesses for just building them so
building businesses very sexy heroic
you're a genius
you're Steve Jobs by business buying you
know a business that does two million
dollars in revenue and 1 million dollars
or even uh you don't get that same sort
of props but his take was like I think
that a building is sort of fun and he
still does it but overrated and over
indexed on versus buying where there's
way more opportunities so I thought that
was another one and I went to Canada I
went and hung out with him for a couple
days we almost did business together and
I was like I can't find a flight to
directly to Victoria so Andrew lives in
Victoria which is like a it feels like a
small European town I don't know how
many
to live there maybe 300 thousand maybe
less maybe maybe less actually maybe
200,000 and I was like I can't find a
direct flight it's okay we'll get you up
here and he chartered a jet for me it
was awesome it was great so I'm happy
I'm friends with him yeah he was a good
guy I think we should have on the punch
yeah it's like once a month at the
minimum and it should just be a friend
friend of the show do you want to talk
about something that is that I found on
the Internet I think is I don't know if
it's real or not
tell me more okay so there's this guy
named Sam Evans have you heard of this
person you know you had mentioned his
name and I was like Sam instead of heard
of it sounds like a fake name and then I
googled him and I saw his face I was
like oh I've seen this guy on my
Facebook feed this guy advertises a lot
so tell me about I don't know much about
tell me yeah so the way it started was
he's a New Zealand guy he's maybe 30
years old and he started what he claims
is a consultant consulting business
which basically he would talk to small
barbers or I don't know what type of
small companies small local things that
wanted more leads and he would help them
like optimize Yelp or something like
that and I think that was mildly
successful and from there if he goes
well I'm just gonna teach other
companies how to do this and so he
created a course and he named it
consulting.com and at this point now
there's three courses so the first
course is creating a consulting business
which is like you do stuff for local
companies like to be a consultant yeah
this course teaches you how to be a
consultant obviously that's like the
model lets you make more money teaching
people and then actually doing the thing
and so he it's cost two grand and they
started making money off that and then
that teaches you how to go from zero to
some sustainable business and then from
there there's a $5,000 course which
teaches you how to go from a hundred
five hundred thousand dollar company to
a million dollar company and then
there's a higher end which is 50 grand
and that teaches you how to go from 1
million to eight figures right and his
website like I don't know if this is
like a get rich
scheme like I can't tell because it is
so elaborate that it could be true but
it seems so good to be true and he
claims to do something like 50 or 60
million dollars a year in sales with 50%
margin on his website is consulting.com
yeah great man yeah but like when you
click through it it all seems so good to
be true like there's like video reviews
and I am I know how to like hack that
together yeah of course you can make
something look totally legit in like 6
hours with two rebels but his stuff is
so it's so elaborate so if it is a
scheme and then I looked at his
Glassdoor reviews and like none it some
sometimes I think this adds up to be
legit or this adds up to where this is
just a massive fraud or scam
it's very interesting and so he says on
the website 20,000 active students if we
take the lowest paid plan that you
mentioned mm that's 40 million a year of
recurring revenue well no it's not
recurring it's just a one-time okay
that's 40 million in sales right not
over not and the sale is a digital
course great yeah so it could be very
profitable - ad spend right so maybe you
percent margin or something like that
yeah it's super interesting it's very
interesting but like so you go from
level one beginner level to master to
level three god damn don't you just want
to spend that 50 grand to become a level
3 god but it's so interesting because if
you like if you had cash flow each year
like what's the amount of cash flow that
you need each year to where you think
that you don't like that you couldn't
spend that amount like 20 million
dollars probably right oh yeah I think
that's high I don't think he'd spend
more than 5 million dollars a year net
taxes like after time for taxes yeah
maybe you could dude I think what's two
hundred thousand dollars a month that's
a three million dollars a year I could
spend three million dollars a year
pretty easily doing what I've got a
friends who live in Long Island what
would you do and they spent 80 grand a
month I mean I would I would just have
two huge houses and a full staff to take
care of me I mean would be a company
right I would have a handful of cars
into a nice house and then another house
and the warm weather right and I would
fly private and you're still under the
five million right that's three point
six million that you said so okay maybe
maybe you need tena as a buffer I just
think that you could do it so you're
saying this might be a tremendous
business and it's a little discussion
about detectors go I wanted to know if
you had ever heard of this or if the
listeners ever heard of this and if this
is legit some of our trend subscribers
told me they subscribe to it and they're
like I got I got a lot of value out of
it yeah I would believe that so so I'll
tell you kind of my closest experience
with something like this so first of all
no I've never heard of this and I don't
know any entrepreneurs in San Francisco
where all my friends are from that do
anything like this but the I mean it's
not valuable the closest thing I did to
this was sort of going into the Tony
Robbins pipeline and so I've tried but
much times about Tony Robbins how great
he is and blah blah blah I like him a
lot I got a lot of value got to go into
his workshop it was all with you and I
bet well because it freaked me out yeah
and a lot of people get freaked out of
people's preconception is just this is
like a cult
this guy's a snake oil salesman or
whatever yeah like what am I getting
myself into and I gotta admit like when
I went there I was like okay cool I'm
going but I'm not doing any of that
dancing [__] I'm just uh I'm just here
for the information I'm gonna sit down
I'll be quiet I'm not gonna yell not
gonna hug I'm not gonna dance and he sat
separately so you wouldn't be
embarrassed if you do well my
brother-in-law and we just agreed
beforehand we're like you know we might
end up doing the dancing [__] so you sit
on that side of the room I'm sitting on
this side of the room and let's see we
didn't see each other except for at the
end of the night when the event would
end each day and we would get back
together but anyways by you know our one
I'm dancing and doing all the good stuff
too but anyways it was a lot of value
and you know it cost me like a thousand
bucks to go do this thing
I thought horrendous and then in the
thing like he up smells just like this
guy does right so he's like you know one
of the first kind of I don't know
coaches lifestyle coaches business
coaches out there and he's been doing
this for 40 years now so he went from
audiotapes
two books two infomercials now the
internet like whatever the channel was
he wrote it and was like I'm the
business cares I'm the lifestyle coach
and you know I got a lot of value and at
one point he upsells his business
mastery class or his business mastery
thing it's like okay if you like this if
you like how you're feeling right now
and right after he makes you feel great
he's like you know that table over there
is for anybody who wants to grow their
business it's ten thousand dollars you
spent five days with me and if you don't
get a million dollars of value from this
thing I will give you all your money
back and in the moment I was like dude I
got a million dollars of value today you
know of course I would do that so I
didn't actually sign up for it but our
buddy see him it did and winter he did
so I believe so and so you know sorry
see if I got that wrong but I'm pretty
sure he told me he did and I have
several friends who actually did it as
well and they said they're like yeah
it's great
and if you have a business that's doing
you know if you have a business your
size right your business is worth tens
of millions of dollars if you can get a
sort of 2 percent 3 percent 5 percent
lift yeah in your business just through
improving your own psychology your own
enthusiasm your own tactics
it's obviously paid itself off right so
how does the infrastructure of this work
like I'm looking at it now does you just
Tony Robbins literally have to be at all
the things no so well he does his live
events yes so he's the Traveling
Salesman that does the live events and
he probably does I don't know I'm gonna
get it wrong but like let's call it 20
to 40 live events a year a lot that's a
lot you know every week he every week or
two he's somewhere and then he has his
sort of like army of like coaches that
are trained under him bit by the way
they all seemed garbage and so he has
this you know the people who are the
actual coaches that will call you and do
all this other stuff with you they are
you know like there's like a fleet of
them I don't know a hundred and hundred
people that and just need a coach
structure is garbage those people are
garbage when I met them I was not
impressed in fact on the days so tell
her I'm gonna do this for 40 years to
the point where he's been public
speaking on stages hype and crowds up
for like 40 years
right so he can't actually do two days
back-to-back so he does day one and it
goes from 8 a.m. till 1 a.m. and there's
no breaks you can go to the bathroom but
you
missing the action when you go it has
just talk and the whole time he's on
stage he's talking and he's got 10,000
people in an audience I've been twice
now I should have been three times that
so the first time I was just
experiencing it the second times I was
observing it because I took a fleet of
friends I bought tickets for my family
and friends I was like this is the best
gift I can give you and they loved it
most of them and so anyways he holds
people's attention for like 14 hours
straight which is incredible you know
you can't most people can't you know
listen to a six-minute youtube video and
have their attention held but then the
second day it's not him on stage because
his vocal cords are shredded so he can't
speak the next day and this like his
number two comes up and this guy is a
good public speaker but he's not like
it's like Michael Jordan and then you go
down to BJ Armstrong and it's like oh no
I came here to for Michael Jordan and so
literally this guy just he says stuff
and then he tees up a video of Tony
talking 10 years ago when he used to do
this like he used to do all four days
himself oh my god he queues up the the
video of telling me and you sit there
and you're watching youtube videos with
10,000 other people and this guy is just
moderating it it's like this bizarre
experience that's crazy I didn't really
sell it very well but I'll tell you this
that was probably the best the best
money I've ever spent on anything
self-improvement wise if you add up all
the books or anything else it's not even
close maybe I should do it you stole you
should totally do it I took about 20
people so I paid for 20 people's tickets
to go see gran yeah I basically became
an affiliate for him I didn't get paid I
just I believed in it so much I paid for
20 other people to go and since then and
it's been four years since then and of
them I would say four people were like
me where they were like a holy [__] life
changed that was the most valuable thing
it's a 4 out of 20 let's say and then
another let's call it I don't know 15
were kind of like that was amazing and I
talked to him a year later they're like
disappointed in themselves that they
didn't carry it forward they're like God
it was so good and I had so much clarity
and I had so much energy but I'm kind of
mad at myself I just kind of let it fade
from there like I really remember
I just remember what I felt then and
yeah I guess I didn't really get too
much value because I'm not doing any of
the things I wanted to do you know after
that weekend well and then there's no
three or four people that literally left
they were like this is way too culty
this is pop science I don't like this I
don't believe this I don't like how he's
manipulating everybody I'm out and I was
like okay that's the spectrum anyone I
know um Alex from calm the founder of
calm he hated it and so he just went for
a bike ride and I think in the middle of
one of the days because he was like it's
just too much for me he's like I don't I
didn't I didn't feel good and what was
going on and so I left I rode my bike
around the city and I had fun doing that
and what was the number one takeaway for
me oh dude I have a notepad full that I
call the Bible cuz I was like this is
the closest thing that I have to
religion right it's like religion and it
smelled like God religion is like an
operating philosophy for life right
that's what that's what people use
religion for them anyways like you know
don't harm your neighbor blah blah blah
like it's an operating philosophy so
this was an operating philosophy so I'll
give you two of the Nuggets right so the
first one is the quality of your life is
equal to the quality of the emotions you
have on a day to day basis so what is
that mean it's kind of a mouthful but
like we're both in a good position we're
very privileged or more successful than
we ever thought we would be seven years
ago probably like the position we're in
now seven years ago us would have been
envious of that but your happiness is
not like ten times more than it was
seven years ago right like you're
probably feeling about the same and the
reason why is that you know life is not
about you know what you have and what
you've achieved it's about who you've
become and so what most people what most
people miss is that if you are it
doesn't matter if you're rich doesn't
matter if your family doesn't matter if
you have a you know if you're famous if
the emotions that you're feeling on a
day-to-day basis are stressed then you
have a shitty quality of life if you're
feeling anger or upset then you have a
shitty quality of life regardless of
everything else and so then the question
is how do you figure out how to like
change your emotions on a day-to-day
basis so you're feeling good every day
regardless of your situation
it's the ants and select so he gives you
three three you like to lose all right
here's the three ways you change how you
feel
the very first thing is your butt is
physical so if you change your if you
have a radical chains and your
physiology calls it which it basically
means if you did a bunch of push-ups if
you're exercised if you ran if you
jumped into a cold pool or or why people
like taking out hot showers it's a
relaxed the fastest way to change how
you feel is to physically change your
body in fact Emmett who's the CEO twitch
was telling me the other day or he was
kind of talking about this on Twitter
people have panic attacks and when you
have a panic attacks really
uncomfortable feeling
and most people panic attacks really
want a solution of like how do I not get
these and I take medicine and so some
people take medicine and that's one way
to change your physiology is chemically
changing your physiology what most
people try to do is like people try to
help people think their way out of it
they're like oh just no don't be so
anxious and you need to just relax I'm
like as if that can help
that's like best if that was that easy
yeah we would all do it and actually
what science has shown is that the
fastest most effective kind of quick and
dirty way to stop a panic attack is to
plunge your face into really cold water
if you do that right at the start of
panic attack it will stop it because
your fight-or-flight will kick in and
it'll override that and so one time one
time I accidentally ate brownies up my
roommate made and they turn out to be
edible brownies and I don't smoke weed
and I hate weed so much like I don't do
any of that and I was like James I'm
flipping out he goes yeah I'm sorry
those were weed brownie and I I started
having a panic attack and I went and
gotten a cold shower and that was no
help
oh nice okay yes so that's fastest way
to change what you feel is your body
either through heat cold or getting your
heart rate up and exercising and it
doesn't be like go to the gym it can be
like if you did ten jumping jacks you
will feel different than you did but
right before that the second one is
focused so what are you going to focus
on so you you know where you place your
focus is going to judge how what your
brain is what your brain is basically
signaling to your body of how to feel so
if you're focused on pain then you're
gonna feel shitty if you focused on how
somebody did wrong how this
cut you off in traffic you're gonna get
outraged but if you focus on things
you're grateful for if you focus on
things are going well if you focus on
things that are that you can trust that
you can rely on you'll feel different
and then the last one is I think it's
like language so you language your story
which is basically the words you use in
the store you tell yourself the big the
big idea and I recommend this to anybody
who's in business which is the quality
of your results is linked to your
quality of your decisions and the
quality of your decisions is linked to
the quality of the internal monologue
you have so the conversation you have
with yourself ends up dictating the
decisions you make which ends up
dictating the results you get and that's
kind of what I pulled away from the
whole thing and then it's a whole bunch
of strategies to do that better I think
you just saved me a thousand dollars
well you got to get up and dance with
the wise in the state this is awesome oh
yeah I always hesitate to talk about it
cuz it's like I'm a preachy
but I think it helps some people it's
never preachy when you can make fun of
it so like you you do a good job of
making fun of something and then you
explain what it is
so that's never preachy all right let's
do let's do a little different let's do
we started this joking segment called
the billionaire of the week
Billy of the week and I think we should
actually continue it I loved it I owe
your guys save your Neil I went and look
you talked about him two weeks ago and I
went and read all about him he mostly
speaks French and all this talks on
YouTube so it was kind of marred - you
got to read along he's badass I love
that guy okay and you had one that you
were thinking about who's the week yeah
let me pull my note so his name's
Michael lo have you heard of him I had
not okay so Michael Loeb in the 90s I'm
pulling up my notes he started this
thing called synapse group and basically
what they did was this was before a lot
of things were popular on the internet
and so they patented I don't know how
they did this there must've been
something unique about it but they
patented the subscription model
I don't yeah I don't know like how that
there's some really maybe great things
that are a little bit beyond what I'm
able to understand but whole day it made
money off that patent or the
but everybody does it well so they they
just trade a unique way to do it and I
think I don't know exactly how it worked
but basically Time magazine Meredith
which is a huge magazine publisher all
these magazine publishers would pay them
money to get them more subscriptions
because this way in which they were able
to get people to renew subscriptions
must have been fantastic and it worked
really well I don't understand how it
worked then basically what it seems now
is like a really robust affiliate
network so like Meredith will cross sell
Meredith which is a three billion dollar
company based out of Minnesota I believe
bought the company synapse for a lot of
money and they deployed it across all
their brands so it's kind of he made it
big through the synapse group which was
a magazine subscription thing yeah it
definitely made him wealthy he didn't
make him a billionaire but it made him
he definitely got wealthy what made him
really wealthy was with his co-founder
of synapse he wasn't sort of Christ
flying and Priceline eventually I think
are they are they owned by Expedia or
they don't think I'm not sure looking
looking so it now it's just a huge you
know huge thing so that made them very
wealthy but what's interesting is after
that he started like the what used to be
part of just like a rich entrepreneurs
playground where they just launched
companies right
it's called Loeb and Loeb NYC and
they've started a whole bunch of
companies including a company called I
believe it's called scrip relief do you
know what that is no so what you do is
you go to it they started companies like
or they use they used to own script
relief and then they renamed it just
something else but basically what you do
is you go to the website and you can get
discounts off of your pharmaceutical
drugs and so like if you want to buy if
you have Zanna X or some type of acne
medicine or something like that somehow
they they they get access to these deals
and use that coupon code at CVS and you
get a discount and it's paid for sending
CVS business and they made that business
we talked about on the podcast call oh
thanks
that'd be to be gifting things which
like it's in their area yeah so they
and he owns a lot of them and a
business-like script relief was making
something like 100 million dollars a
year in profit and so some of his
companies are really big
now here's another reason why he's
interesting do you ever watch that TV
show billions of it
you know the house at Bobby Axelrod okay
that's his house that's Michael Loubs
house okay last year or two years ago
Michael Loeb had a big party
like a fundraiser like a sophisticated
thing and his son brought some friends
along and some of the 18 year old
friends got drunk and started kissing on
the front yuan and just looking like a
fool and soullow punched one of the kids
in the nose and broke his nose and might
go to jail for it he just punch this kid
one time but he hurt him pretty bad he's
a bit of jail for just that they're
they're trying to get him to go to jail
for that I mean that's a salt if you
Burt if you hurt someone you can get one
if you weren't a billionaire you
definitely could go to jail for that
they're trying to get him to go to jail
I have a feeling he's just gonna write a
fat check I mean yeah like kid was it's
probably just a rich snobby so where do
you see this Scripps thing there's not
even on their website I talked to people
who work there ah Sam doing this thing
investigative journalist Sam I like it
there so Google and let's see Michael
Loeb Google Michael Loeb scrip relief
it's it's on his LinkedIn yeah I see it
now
it's renamed something else though do
you say what it's renamed to I'm
checking but you know it's logging into
LinkedIn is like you know taking the
first ten steps into Hill so I'm gonna
try this now
scrip relief was recently sold to United
Healthcare over five million users yeah
so it was sold to someone else and now
it's called something else but he just
has like a web of companies and he's
just super interesting because this is
gonna sound weird when you look at this
guy do you do you think this guy looks
like a billionaire does this guy look
like a successful guy no that's why he
doesn't he looks like a guy who would
punch a kid in the face yeah he looks
like a guy he's like better
about his life and punch the kid with
face for that reason not punch a kid in
the face because he's a billionaire and
the kid Distan his pool oh he looks like
he would be punching kids in the face
regardless of what his financial status
was that's why he's interesting to me so
I have such a mugshot Google is able to
go looks like he looks like he looks
like a tough guy
yeah he looks yeah he looks like a tough
guy he looks like an enforcer that a
billionaire would have he's a building
of he looks like a billionaires enforcer
yeah that's why I think this person is
interesting because dang they have a
picture of the kid who did not expect to
just see those two side-by-side that's
yeah this is quality this is quality
Google when they are searching it's good
right look at that kid he definitely has
a punchable whole face
yeah well the kid looks like he did
something he's even he's like kind of
smug in the picture he's a broken nose
he's in the hospital shirts covered in
blood he's got a little smirk on him
yeah super interesting person right yes
okay I like this guy I never even heard
of this guy I feel like you know a bunch
of these guys that are like the either
media Titans or like these other like
New York you know New York rich people
I only know like San Francisco were like
Dubai rich people I know them because I
spend time I'm a Wikipedia because my
way of building businesses is I'd like
to see what has worked and I I reverse
engineer how it worked and I'm like I'm
gonna deploy that on my company right
and when I'm reverse engineering things
I'll like read about the company right
well now see who started it and I'm like
no wait that guy started it oh but he
was friends with this person and they
partnered previously I bet he had access
to that's probably how so like I like
under so I just like reverse engineer
things yeah I like that and then you
call people which most people don't do
you get up the phone you start calling
people work at the company you get that
extra 10% that you needed right to get
lots of helps because oh I've made
friends but someone who started his
thing so now if I want to meet him I
have it in right so okay so I have
another example of what you just said I
was gonna save this guy for next week
but we're gonna do a double billionaire
of the week so we're doing a double
Billy special get your get your Billy's
right now
Richard Burton okay say have you heard
of this guy Richard Burton is it Burton
Snowboards no so this guy I started a
couple of different companies so it's
just if you just google Richard Burton I
did earlier and nothing came up
did I saying his name wrong I think he
got it wrong because I did no no okay he
Barton sorry
Barton not Burton okay so Richard Barton
so this guy started Zillow he also
started one of your favorite sites class
door he also started he has three so he
has Zillow he has glass door and what's
his other one I was just research this
for next week so we're just gonna do
this live here and he did Expedia in
Expedia board of directors on Netflix he
did Expedia Zillow and Glassdoor
what a [__] baller okay yeah yeah so
ok so how did this happen so I've
listened this interview with this guy
like five years ago before this podcast
even started before this podcast was
even a little you know sperm in my balls
and when I when I looked at this guy the
one thing that stood out to me was he
had a very simple thesis that he used to
start all these companies which was
information wants to be free so K what
does information wants to be free man so
he was basically like I'm gonna bring
transparency to industries that are that
are not transparent and so he said you
know let's take Zillow for example
before Zillow when they sort of online
house propane and house search companies
existed like Trulia and all this red fan
stuff like that the MLS listings were
something that only the agents and
brokers had access to and so this is
they were dick keepers they were like oh
you want to know what's on the market
let me literally print out the MLS
papers and I'll show you the show you
these and all tour you through these
companies that's so great line dude
information that one information once
you got information wants to be free and
so then he did the same thing in travel
right we had travel agents who were the
brokers who you had to call and be like
hey I'd like to get a flight I don't
want to pay too much and that you just
trust it hopefully this agent is gonna
do we were gonna do their job they're
gonna know all the different options
different times different airports and
they're gonna find me something that
fits my needs and Expedia was just a
search bar that would just tell you
here's all the flights you decide here's
the information
you don't need to go to a travel agent
anymore and Glassdoor is the same thing
you wanted to know what's it really like
to work there and employers have no
desire to put that out there they don't
want anybody to know any of the bad
things that happen you know the working
environment of their company and
employees were often scared to do it
because they would sign things so it'd
be like you know non-disclosure whatever
non slander if you're the term for it is
non-disparagement and so Glassdoor was
unleashing the information about what's
it like to work at X company and so I
love how this guy literally on one
thesis has started three multi-billion
dollar companies off that one premise
and so that was when I when I did what
you're talking about I reverse
engineering how did this guy do it it
wasn't oh how did he build Expedia how
did he build illah it was how did you
even get this idea oh okay what other
industries today lack transparency where
I can open them what are they do well if
now that's a billion-dollar idea I need
to have let's think of some one of them
is pricing for enterprise software right
what is find out how much money your
company makes and then they go okay
we're gonna charge you this right I like
that like like I hate that call for
pricing model I mean I I hate it but it
works we do it so AngelList did this in
a way as well when you were able to
figure out who's invested in what that
used to be like sort of not easy to find
information it wasn't sort of like
totally guarded but I crunch mice as
well I'm literally just looking at the
tabs that I have open right like Yelp
yeah I'll put something like that too
you know how what is like to eat there
the review system it organized and made
public information that people wanted
that was not super transparent before
this yeah I mean housing he did that
there's a lot there's so many good ones
um salaries he did that with glass door
there's cost reduced salaries yeah so
there's there's one that I use that's in
the tech world called levels I think we
talked about it what's before but they
do it where with just the like kind of
tech companies it's like what do people
had tech companies make and a lot of
people have been doing this on
insight company so inside Microsoft for
example they created an anonymous Google
Doc where you could just put your level
your job category like engineer or
designer person whatever and your salary
your pay and then plaster that's uh yeah
figure out am i underpaid but but this
was even in like more specific it was
like in a company these are people now
like and it's not just glass door it's
like just a few who kind of go and post
this stuff but they're get like these
these companies are having alleys like
really rich documents with thousands of
people contributing and and right now
those are just Excel Docs I wonder if
you could take the just a salary
component of maybe what same glass door
and do it in a better way
inside company so people make sure
they're not getting the short end of
stick within their own company right now
that's interesting another one is
freelancers so the answer is what real
answers and agents these so the problem
with a lot of the stuff is when we're
trying to hire some agencies to
WordPress development I have to
back-channel and go find out from people
who work with them what they were like
okay once I sign up to and agree with
them I can't I won't find out unless I'm
on a weekend they suck not right I can't
believe I'm in and that's the same thing
with like payroll software to like gusto
looks good but when you sign up to it
you don't realize like what you like and
what about it so we have a couple
friends who are doing things that are
trying to put up you know they're trying
to make information would come free of
what software do companies use so like a
lot of people would want to know what
does the hustle use what do you guys use
to send email what do you guys use for
analytics what do you guys use for your
payment paywall what are used for trends
and like I know Ryan and producthunt
they're doing this with something called
stacks or your stacks and they want to
know what's your software stack that
your company runs on and it's an
interesting idea he's designing it kind
of like a social network but the value
in the end and if you did if you get
there is oh cool I can now go see okay
if I'm building an Airbnb type company
what do they use to run their company
what do they usually do you think that
that is not working well it's really
tough to
is one of those things where really
valuable if you get they're really tough
to get the information in because you
have to get the incentives right later
on you have the incentive to come to
this site because you want to see what
other people use but what's the
incentive to post and so he's trying to
make it fun and interesting and cool to
post by making it like very visual like
sort of a get it doing that
a profile for your company right like
like yeah we use this stuff and so I
don't know the numbers on how it's doing
but I do think it's an interesting
experiment and I think if they did it it
would be the most valuable thing that
producthunt has built because it's a
it's just inherently surely there's a
great business model on top of that if
you can show what's off for people who
use that's cool I agree that's
interesting
I love this idea of information needs or
information wants to be free
yeah let's think more about that so I
think we'll come back with an example of
information today that is either behind
a walled garden or it's incomplete and
if you set it free it would make people
make better choices or save them money
or whatever it is like maybe it's
something in the insurance it's base
maybe I don't I don't know exactly what
but I'm gonna think about this because I
think this is a formula for building
really big companies yeah for me it's
how much things cost like like
freelancers and lawyers and things like
that that's it's always bothered me I
don't like I like my lawyer could be
like yeah we charge $700 an hour and I
was first getting going I was like I
have no idea is that normal right
and on the other side it's also how much
companies make right like you love it
when you hear that a company's public or
it's a non-profit cuz you're like yes
I'm gonna get to their financials is
they have to report yeah well and they
do in a really interesting way and
they're owned by a publicly traded
company they do about a hundred twenty
million dollars a year in revenue
but they do like 25 grand for a
pitchbook subscription right really
expensive and they do about 120 they're
owned by mmm is it called Morningstar or
it's a company right SR I think at this
morning star or morning stores like the
mutual fund thing it's yeah it's owned
by one of those things and I just read
their their earnings thing morning's
target is morning server and they are
the mutual fund thing too
and what they do is they do
two different things the first thing
they do is they crawl the web and they
find SEC documents and they find like
all type they just crawl and find data
and they have a team of like 300 people
who just hit the phones all day and call
people and get the information okay and
then the other one that's like that is
you know even for podcast when we look
at the top charts and we're like alright
how do we become the number one business
podcast we don't know how much we want
my downloads they get right there's this
idea of how much something is how much
is being earned how much is something
making and how much does something cost
I think that just generally would apply
to a whole bunch of different spaces
that you could you can use for this yeah
that's why I use a similar web cuz they
show me how much like traffic guess
traffic one of the dope ones of this do
you use second measure yeah they're
great they're great I think a little bit
expensive they are yeah if you don't
know the arts the second measure takes
credit card spending data and can tell
you essentially like how much money
something is making just by analyzing
how many people are charging Spotify per
month and then they're like oh cool
imagine spot if I was not public company
you'd be able to see here's how much
revenue that they're making they do this
with like the delivery companies which
delivery companies winning well they can
just check this huge data set of credit
card spending and say okay it looks like
grub hubs in the lead and then second is
door - or whatever and so second measure
is super powerful using a source of
truth which just credit card data how
they get out we talk about this stuff
all I want to do is those like and the
podcast and make my days 50 hours long
and just start a search everything this
whole this whole data or make
information or finding information wants
to be free that whole concept that's
amazing
that's the test I want people to listen
this podcast and be so excited and then
I want you to feel anxious I want you to
feel stress that you don't have 50 hours
in your day to go do this and that's
that's how this should feel I've heard a
bunch people say like yeah I have to
keep pausing the podcast to like a write
[__] down B take a breath C think of it
think about what's going on and then I
resume it and yeah that's what we want
it's that that high value you don't
think about one more thing yeah which
one you see you you look at the list
tell them which one you want to do what
happened you've lost five million
dollars
all right I didn't exactly lose five
letters but I did not make the five
million dollars that I could have made
all right so this is called Shawn's
shitty investments this is a new segment
we created just now and I'll tell you
about two bad investments in one good
investment I made so I was talking to a
friend of mine a guy had been aided in
advising this guy about his startup this
is maybe four or five years ago
I've been advising him he didn't live in
America he was building a product for
international his product was around
international students applying to US
universities and making it easy if you
don't know if you live overseas like I
finished high school in China so I saw
this firsthand if you're in China you're
in India you're in Malaysia the goal
like your life goal is to go to a u.s.
University don't even matter if it's a
good one but it's to go to a u.s.
University and even if US universities
overcharge for for that and and they get
in trouble about - sometimes yeah
actually right now there's bunch stuff
in the news because they charge like
three times more for the state is in
trouble because they have like 60%
Chinese nationals there and they're like
right what the [__] you guys are
charging 60 grand for these kids exactly
so so anyways I was helping this guy
great founder really like the company
was really interested but I was at a
point at that time financially where I
was like okay if I'm investing in
startups it's pretty irresponsible
investment because you know when you
invest in startups high likelihood of
failure so you need to place like 25-30
bets and so if you say okay I'm gonna
place yeah 25 30 bits and each bets
gonna be 25 grand like I'm basically I
need to have five hundred thousand I
don't have $750,000 that I'm gonna put
into this which means that can't be like
your whole net worth which is like well
this would that would have been 75771
fifty grand at that time would have been
more than my whole net worth and so I
knew I didn't have the the sort of
bankroll to do it but that was an excuse
I could have found a way I could have
thought to check any ways I could have
banked on myself making more in the
future like I did and bottom line is I
didn't so I would have been the first
check into this guy's company and my
sort of $25,000 check which I was very
very close to writing would have become
five million dollars
this guy's business by now wait what's
the name of the company say the name and
how big is it now I'll just tell you the
name we'll bleep it out so it's called
and so he told me that they just crossed
it you know the billion dollar valuation
and and so I don't know if they're
exactly at that onething a little over a
little under but the point is they're
they're doing well and and so yeah I was
kicking myself because that would have
been a big investment
he's happened to me this has happened to
me now two different times where I could
have I could have been one of the angel
checks into a business I thought it was
a good business I didn't pull the
trigger and those two would have
combined to be worth you know ten
million dollars plus by now what was the
only one calm yeah so this company this
studying abroad company they're do they
make a lot of revenue or is it just
yeah revenue and even then like this was
they were preview at the time but I was
doing the math and I was like wait like
they had an LOI signed by a bunch of
universities and I was like wait so if
they just matched the supply and demand
like this things there make money do
them enough conviction and it's just a
bleach insight no no it's a full
software tool that let that actually
does the application for the student the
University of was a SAS company it's a
free SAS tool for the user and then it's
a lead gen on the other side when a kid
gets accepted they get paid that way got
it and they charge to universities money
yeah like thousands of dollars per
student yeah so okay so they don't
charge the money for the software no
this offers used by the actual student
and customer so anyways it was a it's a
great business big mess on my part happy
for the guy though he is an awesome guy
and I really I like this guy's energy a
lot kind of sometimes you meet people
who got I just have good energy I don't
know how to describe it he was one of
those people's and you know MGM so not
again so basically I haven't talked
about this on the podcast but I during
co vid I decided to mess around with
option trading which you know famous
last words
and so I was literally this is how dumb
I am right so so I don't play in the
finite that
public markets that launch I just do
very simple things I just buy companies
I think are good for the next 10 years
or i buy index funds I don't do a whole
I don't do like day trading I don't do
their leverage buying or I don't do
shorts but I was like you know what I
don't see any way that MGM which is MGM
Resorts I was like I don't see any way
that their business doesn't go down with
this coded thing and so I was thinking
about it and it got cut by like 75
percent so the stock price dropped from
I don't know it was like 25 dropped from
30 down to like 12 and and I was like
yeah I still think that this thing is
gonna go down and so I'm literally on
one tab I have like a Khan Academy video
of like what the hell is a put and on
the other hand I've got my Robin Hood
account and I'm like just pushing
buttons and so I pushed a bunch of
buttons and I placed this trade which
basically said okay I think I'm James
gonna go down and yeah about $2,000 with
options and like let's see what happens
and it turns out MGM didn't go down but
I needed it once I understood my own
trade which was like after I placed it
cuz I was again just put your buttons
what I was looking at the like
confirmation I was like should this a
horrible trade like I I just basically
said that this is gonna go down 40% in
the next seven days didn't you lose
stupid so that's my bad the two bad
investments I want to share on the other
side other side I've been really big
into Bitcoin and when it dropped to like
4,500 recently and now it's back up so
that one made back money from for the
buy shitty option trading in Spain I I
completely stay away from stocks I only
buy S&P 500 or Facebook stock and about
two weeks ago when it was at the bottom
I was like I was like well no when the
whole market was real low like the
lowest point maybe ten or two weeks ago
I sold most everything and I was like I
was like I think it's just gonna get
worse and worse and worse because
unemployment and unemployment comes out
and it's the highest it's ever been and
or the unemployment where claims and
then the stock market goes up 20% I like
I just don't understand how this I know
I don't understand how this works at all
because and then I applied for the loan
for for that Trump enacted and I'm like
so you telling me we get free money that
sounds great but you start thinking
about it you're like I'm gonna pay for
this eventually like somehow I'm there's
no such thing as free or we're gonna pay
for it eventually and so this money it's
just this whole situation it doesn't
make sense to me because the stock
market should be going down yes this is
a dead cat bounce or like sort of a
false rally but forgetting forgetting
the market right now because I don't
know [__] about it and who also who
cares not that interesting it's a
speculators game though there's a phrase
I learned that I thought was pretty cool
it's called a Kings EMU he contests you
know two kings in beauty contest is okay
so have you ever heard of this sort of
economists full names like Maynard John
Maynard Keynes or whatever anyways he's
famous guy in the world of economics
Keynesian economics and a Keynesian
beauty contest describes this phenomenon
where let's say there's a what you think
the stock market should be is here's the
asset here's a company you can buy some
of their stock and you buy it if you
think that the companies cannot become
more valuable than it's priced at today
that's what we think should be happening
but what's actually happening is this as
a speculator market right it's a
speculation driven market and so you
don't in a short time horizon you don't
you're not betting that the company is
going to improve and actually generate
more revenue and what not you're just
betting that other people are going to
think this is more attractive but
they're also bidding that other people
are going to think more attractive so
it's qingzi beauty contest is where
you're not actually judging the beauty
of it you are thinking what the other
judges would think about this thing and
they're thinking about what the other
jesters think about this thing and it
becomes this sort of speculative loop
and that's my sort of Wikipedia page of
the week
that's exactly how things working and it
just annoys me so much you have so much
more control over your life when you
actually run the business right and
there's also a great phrase which is
sort of in the short term the stock
market is a popularity contest and in
the long term it's a weighing machine
and I think that really describes it
well right so like is this also for
private companies as well and when
you're you're raising a Series A in your
hyped company it's a popularity contest
and what
how did this valuation that doesn't make
any sense like yeah it makes sense if
you if you understand that this is
currently a popularity contest but over
the long haul it does not remain a
popularity contest it becomes a weighing
machine and if you're a full of air and
there's nothing there like your value
will go down and so for all those people
who don't understand those valuations
that's why it's frustrating
I'm just so I don't I don't do anything
in that world because I just nothing I I
don't know anything about it and I don't
want to know like it makes me too angry
okay cool do you want to squeeze
anything else in or you want to we could
wrap it tell people about the other
podcast you guys are doing yeah we just
launched one with Moyes Ali which you
should go on it Sean I had a I went on
it to help Moyes interview better but
it's called exit strategy so Moyes
started this company called native and
he started it me and Moyes started our
companies in the same name office and so
I saw him started from nothing so I'm
get the idea and start this thing and he
started this deodorant company called
native in 20 months after starting it he
sold it for a hundred million dollars in
cash I've been 28 months months and so
he decided to launch a podcast because
he is looking for a new project where
he's interviewing other DDC founders and
it was talked about scaling and selling
their companies it's called exit
strategy the Google the hustle exit
strategy or just look it up in on the
Spotfire podcast or you'll see it yeah I
started listening to it
I'm like five minutes in but so far so
good we'll see you crazy I told my
feedback to him was for the next
episodes Beacon to lean into being crazy
don't hold back yeah that would be my
advice as well which is don't I think
when you're when you're a really
interesting person and actually your
opinions are more interesting than your
questions in many ways you need to make
it a conversation a debate more than a
interview because I think what's gonna
end up happening is that Moyes is gonna
be end up being more interesting than
most of his guests and so what he should
do to raise both people's levels is for
him to just act out we would normally
act in a conversation with that there's
anyone would rather he like he says the
craziest stuff ever and he's a great guy
but he's a loose cannon and I love that
about him so I need him to remain as a
loose cannon right so check it out exit
strategy we want the
gasps family to get bigger stronger
better every badass entrepreneur who
wants a podcast needs to go to the
hustle and push a button and start their
podcast with the hustle but like it
should be badass interesting
entrepreneurs not you know sort of
judgment I want to start a podcast yeah
but that should be the least interesting
thing you've ever done in your career
yeah we want experts we want experts who
are charismatic not charismatic people
who hope to be experts right and also
not experts were not kids Matt because
nobody wants that either yeah but yeah
that's out and yeah and people even
reviews I read all the reviews everyone
could see yelling at me because they say
my mic sucks I so I ordered a new one
but everything's back ordered you might
have a new mic coming doesn't know
essential the essentials are micro sorry
let's read one review let's do it a
reviewer of the week let's give somebody
a shout here so I scan these for one
second okay so three stars Sam can learn
how to talk into a mic but both these
guys are very knowledgeable and give
infesting a fresh young spin I've been
listening just since it was just Sean
spelled my name wrong and loved it but
when Sam came on it became different Sam
gets excited
his voice pops into the mic yeah but
come on that's the excitement Sam she
loses the podcast not gonna do it you've
got to listen to yourself you can tell
Sean speak softer Sean misspelled again
and tries to get Sam to quiet down but
it's not working that's not true okay
let's look at another below these are
interesting that the hybrid Hughes
although I want the high reviews but
well we have like 800 reviews and almost
all are 5 stars the only ones that are 5
stars are the people who cost unethical
which is [__] there are people who
say that my mic sucks which is [__]
and the people who just call us bros
also [__] well no mess I'm [__]
I am a bro means a man yes that's that's
me all right see s value says very smart
guys would not recommend hello the title
for a review
these guys are very smart and you'll
certainly learn the finger to about
making money by listen to this podcast
that said it's not worth the subtle
recalibration of your moral compass I
don't know that's a decision for each
listener to decide ok so then they say
these are not high integrity people
here's their examples of why were not
high integrity we asked people to sub an
unsub to game the podcast algorithm give
me a break yeah a joke
laughing about lying on a job
application and getting caught
I didn't laugh because I thought it was
good I laughed because that's the way
you deal with heartache I laugh to cover
the pain don't you understand yeah like
I said how I said how that was a
horrible move and I got what I deserved
right casually dismissing a host
criminal record a host yeah no one
dismissed my criminal record they said
it's stupid I shouldn't have done it and
that's why I changed my lifestyle gotcha
these guys are sharp guy is a good at
hustling hacking and scheming but this
is not content I would recommend anyone
put into their brain you know what
welcome if that doesn't make people want
to listen to this more I don't know what
will that's there's our clip for
Instagram like are you looking around
like are we still in the studio and we
have our staff to like whip it it's just
your wife behind you okay cool let's get
out of here we'll be back at Tuesday and
yeah see ya enjoy share the pod
[Music]